it feels so good to be back on the stage
because
uh you know covet has really hit
everyone especially the
entertainment industry so but it's given
me an opportunity this past year to
really
focus and figure out exactly what kind
of show i want to do i've been writing
an
album my 63rd album and it's going to be
a show trying to encompass six decades
of music in 90 minutes and
it's gonna be a challenge but it's it's
gonna be me i've put together
a crack team of people i mean uh raj
kapoor is gonna be directing this thing
and if anybody knows anything about raj
they're gonna say well you got the best
in the business
and uh we can hardly wait to get started
it's a lot of work
but august 31st is not that far away
because that's when we start
and it's nice to be back at uh at
harrah's
because interestingly enough back when i
was about six or seven years old
my brothers and i were the first act to
open harrah's tahoe
all these years later i'm back at
harrah's so
literally i'm back home i spoke with
marie last night and
and uh she was so excited she says i am
their opening night i've got to see this
show
it's not going to be a rehash of the
donny marie show that's
that was one thing this is something
completely different
and like i said it's more of the six
decades of my
of my life and what i've gone through
the different music uh genres that i've
recorded
um but it's so exciting to be a part of
this and
honored that caesars entertainment said
okay you're one of the first ones that
we're going to announce
in a big way that we're bringing life
back to vegas
now i'm not a doctor i'm not a scientist
but
with all the news from the vaccines and
all that stuff mark my word
las vegas summer of 2021 is going to be
so exciting because
it's going to be a new normal but it
will be back to normal
no no yes performers that's uh unless
somebody shows up and i said hey get up
here on stage i mean that's always fun
to do that's what vegas is all about at
least
that's what vegas was back when i was a
little kid as as
i was growing up if there was a star in
the show bring them up on stage and
perform
that's fun but the show isn't based on
just surprises um however there's a
segment in the show that's going to
change every night
and this has been my challenge what kind
of music
do i present to the audience because
people i was asked
the other day who comes to a donnie
osmond show
and i said well primarily the puppy
lovers but if my social
media has anything to say about that
it's across the board
uh there's a little 12 year old that i
found out that just absolutely
loves this huge fan of danielle 12 years
old how does she know me she said from
i can see your voice and the mass singer
mulan i'm captain chang of mulan all
these other things
so the demographics are so wide and
varied so this segment in the show
henry i'm going to uh have all 63 albums
on this on the screen and they can pick
any album they want
any track i turn to the band three four
and we do the song
and we'll probably do 20 30 seconds of
the song so we get to a lot of different
types of music and different
demographics
and genres within those 90 minutes i've
got some ideas on how to interact with
my
with my fans who i must say
they are the most loyal fans anybody
could ever have
i've have fans that have been following
me since i was five years old
and uh they're still with me and then of
course
new ones as well who just discovered me
you know just recently
but through social media and you know
you got your pros and cons of social
media
i i actually like it because i can stay
in touch with
with my followers and i listen to him
all the time what do you want to hear
what do you want to do this and this
this this
i do facebook live and and i stay in
touch with these people
because i remember it's important to me
because i remember a conversation i had
with
elvis presley he said if i could do it
all over again
i'd get closer to my fans because
they're the ones who put me on this
stage
and i recognize that same dynamic in my
life wait till you walk through this and
i walked through it last night
they have redone everything they
finished all the rooms redid all the
rooms as of january
the showroom is going to be redesigned
and and updated the technology is going
to be completely different
the sound will absolutely blow you away
the visuals
uh the plans that that we have for this
show
i can hardly wait to present it on stage
yes it's going to be
you know a lot of work to get to that
point but when i hit that stage
with all this technology and all these
this
this professional touches that are going
to go into the show
i can hardly wait to present this show
to the public